c'est un retour à la normale près de 11
millions de lycéens chinois ont bien
pris le chemin de l'un des sept mille
centres d'examen met en place dans tout
le pays
contrairement à la france les étudiants
de dernière année du secondaire passe le
concours national d'entrée à
l'université dont des classes la crise
sanitaire presque un lointain souvenir
d'abord j'ai trouvé que c'était un peu
difficile de respirer mais après j'étais
complètement concentré sur l'examen je
ne faisais pas attention aux masses
passer l'examen d'entrée à l'université
dans cette situation particulière de
l'épidémie est une expérience éprouvante
pour lui qui le rendra plus auto
discipline et après avoir révisé est
étudié pour l'examen à la maison pendant
si longtemps un million de surveillants
ont été réquisitionnés pour déceler la
moindre tricherie fièvre ou encore two
suspecte prudence contrôle maîtres mots
d'un gouvernement qui ne laisse plus
rien passer
pour preuve 11 millions de personnes ont
été testées dans la capitale depuis un
mois 5000 ont été placés en quarantaine
partiellement la découverte et début
juin d'un foyer de contamination dans un
marché alimentaire de gros du sud de
pékin avec 335 personnes infectées
semble avoir été maîtrisé les autorités
chinoises ont annoncé jeudi n'avoir
recensé aucun nouveau cas de kovy 19
pour le troisième jour d'affilée
aujourd'hui la chine envoie un message
fort au reste du monde et
particulièrement aux états unis mais je
me dis rien n'est plus précieux que les
vies humaines
rien n'est plus urgent que de sauver des
vies nous avons une profonde sympathie
pour le peuple américain pour ses
expériences malheureuses dû à l'épidémie
et nous avons fourni aux etats unis une
énorme quantité de matériel médical dont
il avait grand besoin
il devrait travailler avec la chine pour
promouvoir la réponse mondiale au coït
19 afin de sauver plus de vies et être à
la hauteur de notre responsabilité
internationale en tant que grand pays
linda ce jeudi plus de 30 diplomates et
experts de haut niveau du monde entier
ont participé à un débat parvis
une conférence un forum sino-américain
après avoir été le tout premier foyer de
l'épidémie
pékin souhaite aujourd'hui rassurés et
prévenir le gouvernement a annoncé
vouloir interdire la consommation et le
commerce d'animaux sauvages ou encore a
déjà stoppé l'importation de produits
aquatiques